what are you learning inside of these
programs
they all are structured a little bit
different but i would say in general the
big takeaways are first of all you're
going to write a new piece of material
and you're going to do it with
professional mentorship so this is going
to be getting notes from people who give
studio and network notes to real
professional writers all the time right
so it's a little bit different than your
writer's group giving your notes or your
friends and it gives you a sense of what
that's like when you're on staff when
you're developing to get notes from
those kind of professionals so hopefully
you have a great new piece of material
to help you secure representation
and to go out for staffing
the programs will also prep you for
staffing
in terms of
executives coming in and meeting with
you and liking you so they'll consider
sending your name to their showrunners
that they're working with who are
looking for you know new writers
also you get practice in how to handle
meetings with showrunners how to go
through a general meeting because like i
always tell people
when i got in the cbs program i would
have treated a showrunner meeting like a
regular job interview because i had no
idea what it was it is very much not
that it is really just go in and have a
conversation with someone
because
the truth of a meeting a general meeting
or a showrunner meeting
is that
you're they already like your writing
that's how you got in the room so now
you're there to show who you are to be
your best self
to make them laugh if you're doing a
comedy to tell interesting stories if
you're doing a drama that's you know
tied to your experience whatever it is
and show them that basically you're a
nice normal person you're not going to
make their life harder and they wouldn't
mind being in a room with you for 10 12
hours a day
and that's half the trick is just being
able to go in and be relaxed and you
know do those meetings
and so that's a big element of almost
every program is teaching you how to
handle that that prep and how to get
ready for those meetings
what are the key benefits that tv
writing programs offer i mean first of
all it's that that experience of
meeting some executives meeting some
managers to get practice for how to do
those kind of meetings
and also introductions right i got my
first agent
through an introduction from one of the
programs i got my manager through an
introduction from one of the programs so
that helps you find representation if
you don't have it
i met tons and tons of executives some
of whom have become close friends over
the years from that those writing
programs
so you have that connection base that
you start to build out
it gives you a cohort of writers to be
your support system as you build your
career
because you need people to you know if
something crazy happens in the room you
need someone to be like on you know on
your break texting going what is this
craziness that just happened is it just
me or is this crazy and they can be like
nope that's crazy just remember take a
deep breath it's all going to be fine
um or to get advice on things when
you're you know you're stuck on a story
point and you're scared to go to the
showrunner and you can have a friend
who's like no it's better go ask the
sharing before you make a mistake in the
script like do it
those kind of things
and then it's also just the
the community that you start to build
i
hate networking it's like one of my
least favorite words
i used to hate when they would be like
we're having a writer's mixer and you
know i would have to go and
full disclosure i still hate the idea of
them
what has happened over the years though
is that i would force myself to go i
would be like just go for an hour just
go for one hour and then talk to a few
people and you can leave
and because i have done that because the
writing programs so often co-mingle and
have crossover you develop this whole
network of people that you are friendly
with and who you like and who are
interesting to talk to
and you build this whole community so
when one of my friends becomes a
showrunner and it's like i need a great
bipark mid-level writer who do you know
we all can respond to that because they
just reach out to their people and then
we all are like oh this person this
person's great i'll have i'll get a
script and send it to you and we can
support each other and help each other
as we all grow through our careers so
that's honestly one of the most valuable
things that comes out of it
and you're kind of with them for life so
to speak a little bit yeah you know it's
like the my
class of
uh from cbs and from nbc we're all still
in touch we're all still very close
we
you know
celebrate each other's wins we
commiserate over our losses it's it's
you know
it's
your little tv family that you build and
then as you build your career every room
you go to you're going to meet people
who you want to know for the rest of
your life you know it won't be everyone
but there's going to be people in every
room that you're like
now you are stuck with me
do you think you would have broken into
television had you not gone through one
of these programs
i don't think i would have to be honest
i think i had tried everything i could
think of outside of the programs
and the one thing i had not been able to
do
was work as an assistant in television
and because i put myself through
undergrad and graduate school and had
very hefty student loans i just couldn't
afford to i did not have the support
system to allow me to make
what assistance make and then also keep
a roof over my head and so that was just
never going to be
a thing i could do
and even when i tried to do it people
were like you have a master's degree you
cannot be a pa and i was like no no i
can i really can
trust me i will make it work and they
were like no we're not gonna we don't
believe you
so
that opportunity wasn't there and i
think were it not for the programs i'm
not sure how i would have ever made it
happen i mean i would have continued to
write certainly
um
would it have been enough to finally get
a door to open i don't know
had you been tempted to leave your
master's degree or even your bachelor's
off a resume so there's some survival
jobs here in la they pay some pretty
good wages
do you think they felt you were
overqualified and it scared them away
yeah
yeah absolutely and
and for me like
you know
the job that i was doing the day job as
much as i hated it it allowed me to
survive and it allowed me to you know
pay all my bills and pay on my loans and
keep a roof over my head
and so it was just like look this is the
way it's going to be and
you know it could have
there it was that push-pull of yes i
could have taken the master's degree off
my resume but so much of what i had
learned about how the business worked i
had learned because of that master's
program because this was before the
writing fellowships right so i was also
cutting down the sense of experience i
had so it was like
you know i'm just gonna try it and
they'll say yes or they'll say no and
they always said no but i'm still here
anyway
what advice do you have to other writers
who are considering these kinds of
programs
my biggest advice is you know when
you're when you're thinking about what
to submit
whether it's a spec or a pilot i think
cbs might be the only program left or
viacom might be the only program left
that's requiring specs
much to my dismay
but whatever it is you're submitting
if you were going to be identified by
one piece of writing
that's the script you submit
because
you only really have that one shot
and then the next year if you didn't get
into any of them you have to have the
next script that is the script that you
would want to represent you
so that's why i say you always have to
be writing because you always need new
material
even once you start your career people
will have read the two samples that you
broke in with and so you have to have
new samples to send out places
so you know always be writing and when
you get to the points in those
applications where they
ask you you know there's always either
essay questions or a video element and
it's like you know what do you have to
contribute to a writer's room
really think about what your life
uniquely offers
to your storytelling
it's not about how much you love tv it's
not about how you've dreamed of being a
writer since you were a kid it's about i
have gone through x y and z in my life
and not trauma
just experiences you've been through it
can be that you you lived in 17 places
because your dad was in the military or
that you
love to hike and you've hiked seven of
the craziest places in the world to hike
whatever it is that's special about you
you want to bring out in those
questions and that response because
that's the stuff that people are looking
for it's like what's the special sauce
you
bring into the room because you know
almost everyone and i do say almost
because not a blanket statement almost
everyone who wants to be a tv writer
loves tv so it's like why you
and that's the question you're really
answering
you